why is it meet kevin tell us yeah why
meet kevin no kidding well
my last name's always been something
people like what's your last name
path path like something what uh so i
went with meet kevin because
it was much simpler than paf wrath when
i started selling real estate
now though that's a little bit of a
problem because when you're running for
governor and you've got three kevin's in
the race
differentiating yourself as meet kevin
doesn't work too well that's what i got
to say i like meet kevin
i actually like you know as a democrat
though running in california did anybody
try to sway you to change your name to
vegetarian kevin oh man
i've had a lot of people tried
vegan kevin yeah my mind immediately as
a political operative my mind
immediately went to meet swing
so you know that's the yeah but
different kind of meet kevin right
completely different how was travel
coming in
tell us about it i'll tell you this uh
when you come into florida and you look
at that sunrise
it just makes you want to go live at the
beach and and you guys have such a
beautiful
beautiful state here so where are you in
california i'm in ventura california
which we've got beaches too
water's a little bit colder and you've
got an oppressive regime that makes life
a little more miserable
are you are you ventura are you oxnard
ventura city of ventura you are invented
yes
okay great yeah i mean i've been a
ventura many many times
ventura is what 10 miles after camarillo
or like 15 miles out aft
after camarillo exactly yeah yeah yeah
yep so it's a it's an interest in
california
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]